greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by on it start the new year off [ __ ]
healthy you made resolutions like a
[ __ ] mom a little vignette now you
got a follow-up on them start with a
luau for brain a little shrimp export
give mama a stab and give you some more
oxygen little shroom tech immune take
care yourself it's a whole new [ __ ]
year as Tony Soprano said be a good
friend to yourself go to Chanukkah might
now impress in church BAM and get 10%
off delivered right to your crib now
since we're starting a new year of
healthy you also want to start the new
year with a clean [ __ ] let me tell
you something the [ __ ] internal system
it starts with the [ __ ] muffler first
once your muffler gets all [ __ ] up it
eats you from the inside out the next
thing you know you're walking around
with it too why don't you wipe your ass
and you left that little peanut on your
ass then the skin grows over your ass
and now you got [ __ ] problems that
[ __ ] ends today why hello Toshi comm is
here to rescue you Oh Joey what's hello
[ __ ] hello - she is a portable bidet
you put your favorite bathroom at the
house and after you take that [ __ ]
[ __ ] of debt you put that [ __ ] water
on it sprinkles your [ __ ] oh yeah
Mexican music even though your [ __ ]
French you might be French and also he's
talking about Mexican music when that
water hits you ass you'll wipe it down a
little antiseptic forget about it your
mufflers clean ready to be licked you
understand me go - a little touchy calm
and press in muffler boom and get 10%
off right now start the gyro of healthy
and start the year off with a clean
[ __ ] alright
take that [ __ ] meal Lee what happy
[ __ ] New Year you dirty [ __ ]
savages I love you we made it another
[ __ ] you believe we made it another
year did you wake up on the first going
what the [ __ ] happened last night and do
dick please I stay on my mind my
business I don't want to see nobody I
want to talk to nobody I don't want to
get no [ __ ] they're beating Jimmy
two-shoes Schubert's in the house let's
shop at me happy new direction [ __ ]
Philadelphia and my man the
[ __ ] got his dick sucked on new
he is like a doctor look at me ready to
go he called me and I was home alone
he's like you gotta do something so I
told
you're 30 years old I give my pinkie to
be 30 I'd be out 10 min on get little
minion that be on my [ __ ] resolution
most New Year's Eve don't jinx me
a quiet chlamydia yeah that's can some
gentle 30 years old I'm staying and
watch [ __ ] now oh you watch inside
man I like good things that was in this
movie as soon as you said that to me I'm
going over then dicksmack years old take
a hit of coke or something do something
you can't stay in the [ __ ] house you
need 30 me I'm 56
what the [ __ ] do I give a [ __ ] yeah it
said those days are going out you know
okay I'm straight I'm over it you know
it's like Amateur Night every comes out
I was actually surprised like more
people weren't like when you're out
there doing the clubs you know it's
always a good night but I'm surprised
well I was but most people were
relatively behaved you know some people
just stayed in the years past you get a
hammer just throwing up in the audience
why people start to do you're off like
that you know you know people people
really don't know you're young you know
people have these New Year's party they
start at 6:00 yeah you know no he do -
bunch of coke at 6:30 you're off and
running by 9:00 o'clock there ain't no
stopping you know Fishlips you only
remember the [ __ ] Bell going down you
know I'm not and that's what happens to
people and listen I'm guilty guilty I
think I did it one year where I got why
and then I didn't I didn't like getting
on New Year's I thought it was bad luck
to be high
I didn't want cocaine in my nose on them
yeah well cause it's a new year you got
new opportunities you got new things I'd
snort my ass off on the first yeah but
on January 1st their world ball games
I'd be snorting and whacking off bang
him without but it's so weird how no
like new he is never really in comedy
I think they taught you the [ __ ]
consumer too much but I don't like that
I want a comedy club patron to have a
good experience absolutely there was one
particular year that I was working that
never one out of my mind and I felt bad
for the consumer in my world I'm not
supposed to think of a consumer but I
don't like getting ripped off
none of us is consumers
like getting ripped off so I'm not
paying double for a [ __ ] comic I
could see yeah so you'd give me a shitty
piece of salmon that Tommy Club salmon
it's got eyeballs and shrimp six
eyeballs his brown skin you know or a
steak at a comedy club I'm not doing it
that's the dumbest [ __ ] thing in the
world that's like going to a strip club
an otter and salmon
the guy's got pubic hair falling on it
and [ __ ] stripper juice and you know
it just doesn't make sense to me I don't
I always think of a consumer how would I
feel you know years ago I got a call
from an ex-girlfriend of mine years ago
and she said she was going to see Jane
Moore and the club she was at was the
worst thing ever that they treated her
like a piece of meat yeah and I always
thought about that you know I've always
thought about how people think as much
as I have no empathy a lot of times
people who might not think I'm in
pathetic I'm very empathetic I remember
working with a comic and me going up to
him as a feature act and being a fan is
like wanting to be like guy and going up
there and going there's a bunch of
people outside that want to talk to you
like 11 people he goes [ __ ] them and I
was like that's a mental note but I'm
not gonna have that attitude
absolutely for that I don't get it
either there's just little little things
that you don't understand I don't like I
don't like shows where people have to
stand
I don't like shows where I have to look
at the audience and then look like
they're [ __ ] in a bat they're just
having a bad experience yeah I don't
like putting audiences because it's not
really well you can make 10 1000 I don't
care yeah I'd rather not make the money
than piss them off and have them come
back a second time yeah then go I went
there and I had a bad experience I know
what clubs I got it's a bad experience
when I'm there I could feel it yeah
those clubs I'll never go back to like I
just won't go back to them yeah because
it's counterproductive what you're
trying to do what you try to put
everybody in a good mood you try to make
them laugh you not mean the whole
purpose of your thing is to make them
laugh and put them in a great mood and
it's really tough to do that if they're
jammed in there's no room to move
they're like you said they're being
you know being charged double or triple
what they pay for a normal show and then
they throw out I mean some clubs do it
right don't get me wrong there's some
clubs that do it right they came to the
food in its top shelf that's you know
and and they want everybody have a good
experience because I think a lot of
clubs think that that's cool like you're
stepping over a dollar to pick up a
penny and yeah that took paid for for
one [ __ ] night those people will
never come back yeah a bad experience so
like you said it's kind of redundant but
you're right some people do it they like
to gouge so it's like price gouging
during a natural disaster like people
raised the gas like three two hours and
it's like [ __ ] what you know it's like
why would you do it to people they're
already down why are you kicking them
you know make sure you have a good
customer experience Plus people to come
to your clubs now they have a great
customer service they'll come back again
and again you're building a brand every
time I come here I see great comedians
sometimes I look them up sometimes I
don't but every time I come to this club
I have a great experience and that's
kind of what you're up against now I
mean it's you know you got a it's like
you know comedy clubs are doing well
Kylie seems to be gonna rise and then
someone goes and there's a bad
experience at Club that's one a little
Club and I feel a bad experience
I don't go to that club again I don't
yeah say it publicly or nothing like
that I just in my mind go if I had a bad
experience they had a bad experience and
like I said you can't make a good you
know well you can't make a good deal
with a bad person if they don't give a
[ __ ] about the audience members or I'm
having a unique experience and then then
fine but I'd be like you said it's funny
and I stand there and shake every hand
on the way out and I thank people for
coming to see my show and you know Larry
the Cable Guy used to do that that is
essential is they want to meet you they
want they had a great experience you
shake their hand you come back next time
and follow me on social media come back
I mean you want to I mean that's what
it's all about that you know these
people have become fans because you want
to nurture oh man tell look around see
future shows I mean I don't know like
you're right that the clubs do that it's
kind of kind of creepy but it's it's
weird how what I learned there's an open
mic er when I went back to Denver in 93
I learned some of my business that was
really weird
you know I had a couple guys at all they
did all day as comics when it was awful
rooms right god bless these guys yeah
God God bless these guys to always be in
my heart because and
those days the major clubs we can give
you stage time yeah you know they had an
open mic once a month on a Sunday and
there was 12 people in there but where
you got better with these bar shows
where there's a Laker game Ellen or a
Bronco game on or a nugget game and you
gotta go on in new comedy that's where
you learn how to become a comic and then
every three weeks you you go to an a
room yeah and you figure out how to put
your bar set into an a set now yeah
because your bar sits a little dirty
it's a little bit more rugged but what I
remember is from all those sessions were
I could always tell the guys that were
fans of comedy and always tell them I'm
talking about the bar owners yeah I
could always tell the bar owners they
were in if the business like a karaoke
right I didn't want to do business with
them right I wanted people that would
say to me hey you know can you get your
me Schubert in here Wow
you know Jimmy Schubert is yeah my
favorites Bill Hicks like those are the
comedy club owners that you want to do
Kali with yeah cuz they care about the
art form and then two weeks going in
that book you mean for second can you
get me fluffy and now you got to bring
them down earth and go
Fluffy's 20 G's yeah oh okay yeah but is
there another fat Mexican out there that
we could say you know they are a fan of
comedy yeah I'll even if they're losing
money yeah they continued the show and I
always loved working for guys like that
yes and I you always loved one you know
why is it open comedy clubs that are
still like that you love working for
guys like that you know because they
they understand that you know the art
form they're fans of it how could you
get mad at a guy who you know creates an
environment for you to make a living
doing something you love to do that's a
fan of the comedy in your informants
gotta love working for those guys that's
like you don't want us there's a lot of
guys you work for that number one they
have when you get to that Club they show
up on Thursday listen if you think after
20 years I'm gonna watch a comment five
nights in a row if I'm the club owner
you got rocks in yet okay I won't see a
[ __ ] comedy yeah I've been here for
16 years working every [ __ ] night
bagging I'll accomplish I gotta kid nice
cool you know this is the essential
comedy club order
will you talk to now when I go to a club
you know like you got a survey from the
airlines now are you satisfied when I go
to a club the first thing I look for is
Thursday night right
I want the homeless show up right if I
[ __ ] them worked on Twitter and social
network and Gabe did podcast to sell
this place out yeah I expect that you
see their shake my hand I don't give a
[ __ ] of you up the rest of the weekend I
rather not have you around your ass cuz
I'm gonna be sparking in here you know
gonna be doing what I do I don't want
you around but I like those guys I like
those guys I call you Friday and go if
you need something call the clock manage
and he'll drive you to whatever ya he'll
need anything
oh yeah but I like those guys that goes
into the package for me it's not the
money I'd rather make less money and get
treated like a human being and for them
to understand you know when I go into a
comedy club and half the staff says to
me I heard the podcast Jimmy Schubert it
that that means the world to me yeah you
know me and leaves do a podcast at a
club where every week the lady would
call me she didn't know what a podcast
was and and I said filly we're never
coming down here again because I can't
deal with somebody when the height of
podcast doesn't know what a podcast is
and managing a comedy club yeah I'd
rather not make that money I'd rather
avoid that whole [ __ ] in the situation
because of you're a fan of comedy and
you're a comedy club manager how don't
you know about the podcast yeah dude and
is the single thing that has make comedy
clubs come back again is the podcast you
would go to Comedy Store you get three
shows or so it's because of the podcast
again these people talk about that place
it's I mean it's right sold out of it I
mean how are you it's like he said how
could you have you business know what a
[ __ ] about yeah
I mean what the [ __ ] is like somebody
know somebody's looking at you know your
your comedy special you're trying to
sell yeah I watched a couple minutes of
it did you not watch the whole [ __ ]
thing just a couple we watch five
minutes of is that enough it's like it's
weird it's the same thing it's like you
know take a minute think I mean you know
how busy are people well here's the
thing the comedy podcast brought comedy
back because
people got to meet who we are now yeah
people get to see the real you you know
for years I thought you know for years I
thought like I said I was a fan like
guys I saw him do HBO specials and I saw
him do young comedian specials and then
I worked through them and I never
[ __ ] pay attention to him again and
now people void all that you know what's
in my heart you know what's in my head
yeah my opinions are on certain [ __ ]
things yeah you know they know people
don't come to a show
very rarely anymore do I see somebody
get up in the middle my son walk up ten
years ago people walked out by the does
this yeah oh no now you found you found
your phone I just you long as you're
yeah people walk out by the handfuls by
the handfuls ISIL now I know they're
getting they know what they're saying
they know where they're coming to say
let's do a little one particular weekend
in Atlanta before laughing skull he had
a big club do you remember yeah life is
good
yes it was it was like an amusement
thing my muse me and the guy rat was
able to pay the committees with the
coins he made off all the abuse yeah
games yeah cuz that place was packed but
the comedy club was like he didn't care
if the audience was a just like I don't
remember it was [ __ ] crazy yeah I
remember going in there I had a
felonious yard on the way in [ __ ]
people were touching me taking Mike in
those days people didn't really bother
you for pictures but then for like doing
different [ __ ] like we can't wait to see
it and I still getting off that stage
and those same people looking away yeah
like I still remember going to all those
rooms and just walking people by the
handful oh you know I did I tell you
truth you know your Kennison used to do
the same thing I went one more as a
doorman at the Comedy Store before he
got his [ __ ] before he was you know
he would [ __ ] a woman because I want you
to take the names of three people who
died that were close to you just write
down the names and three singing and
then put on a napkin and just just hand
them up here so I could wipe
yes people [ __ ] beeline for the door
like they never liked but you know but
that's what happens until you find your
[ __ ] groove you don't mean it like
you know now that people are come and
see you want to come see you they know
what you're doing you know I mean but
it's so funny like people like how
people come to a comedy club and don't
like Google somebody and see what they
do and they get upset in the show room
going I didn't know didn't you [ __ ] a
[ __ ] and all but three I seen three
famous walks yeah the best walk I ever
seen was one of the best walking in Rome
was James and Minh out of Seattle
Washington yeah no James I'm here for a
long effort that name he's crazy
[ __ ] would walk a whole room he
would walk half of it
I'm in kasi Sorbo a blonde little cute
thing from Seattle and they just walk
around over then walk in Bremerton one
night I walk in dirty people
Wow and then but the walk the best
walked out ever was Stanhope 98 Seattle
Washington they were walking out in
packs of threes and he was yelling I'm
gonna go hold on before you leave I want
you to give this tit fight joke or he
would say something why you leaving come
on you know you're gonna go home and
[ __ ] her up the ass and put your dick in
her face
I mean he was insulting them as they
believed it yeah that was [ __ ]
classic like they was walking out in
threes yeah and just I loved that just
but just not giving the happy to give a
file that's a complete different gift no
that is I mean dude I watched [ __ ]
bill burr I was at the show in Philly
with Bill burr got [ __ ] booed I was
getting booed by like ten thousands of
people and just [ __ ] going Adam like
[ __ ] just like weird that sheer
information he had about the city of
Philadelphia and their sports teams and
their losses and Jenna [ __ ] just jam
it down the throat it was [ __ ]
brilliant like just people would have to
be more loving to have the booboo but it
was [ __ ] great I'll never forget I
was watching I'm looking at DOM and Dom
goes he's got 11 minutes left but just
an that billboard I got 11
laughs and I'll do it all what balls
that [ __ ] but that's it's [ __ ] great
I love that what are the options you get
off the stage cause you lose yeah it's a
psychological wash you just lost its you
with a microphone against 300 people
dude that was the first guy out there
they started [ __ ] booming about [ __ ]
I'm gonna sitting there taking [ __ ]
haymaker I'm gonna take your haymakers a
couple minutes till I [ __ ] realize I
go these [ __ ] are boo and I
didn't realize it we're [ __ ] doing it
for us and then they're [ __ ] building
10,000 people and your [ __ ] family
[ __ ] the audience and I know those fans
if I go [ __ ] off on these
[ __ ] I was always supposed to
do like eight minutes anyway and so I
said hey thank you guys been great but
the minute I [ __ ] next to you know the
throne [ __ ] bottles at my head
that's Philadelphia brother they threw
batteries it's [ __ ] you know they
throw batteries and people they blew
Santa Claus they're horrible [ __ ]
people listen I just love Philadelphia
yeah I did too I mean with my art I
belong in Philadelphia so long Mexico
yes my thinking is a Philadelphia I
think of when I think of Philadelphia I
think of getting off the plane and seen
Joe Frazier's gym and my dick and all
right you know that mentality that Joe
Frazier mentality that's the mentality
of the city yeah I remember their
football teams I remember going there to
see the stones yeah I haven't gone there
to see Black Sabbath of a deal you know
I spent that lot of time in Glassboro
college I spent a lot of time at those
stupid cheese shop places which I have
no [ __ ] idea what with the names were
then or whatever
now patching Geno's the cheese day yeah
this is 80 81 82 83 I was in
Philadelphia ten times a [ __ ] year
then when dr. J went to Philly forget
about it yeah I learned Philadelphia I
would go to those games at the spectrum
yeah and save the coupons cause if they
scored over on in 25 points you got a
free hamburger at the corner joint then
there'd be a thousand [ __ ] more yarns
and Chinese people you gotta wait up
they got a free cheeseburger what
happens when you give away a free
cheeseburgers
know what that's like that's like bat
bat day at Yankee Stadium with a Red Sox
incumbent you're just inciting a war
you're saying you're just inciting a
[ __ ] war but what is well-known about
Philadelphia that's how guy why he was
in the 70s they already had a jail at
RFK state or JFK state that's a
courtroom in the jail a courtroom in the
jail this is this just to let you know
people in the 70s if you look at all the
biggest world tours of rock musicians
the first night was always Philadelphia
why to get it out of the way to get it
out of the way we're gonna get tortured
let me tell you how back I go with
Philadelphia just to tell you
[ __ ] I go back to Philly July
anyone look it up and Google me back or
whatever if I'm right or I'm wrong the
day dia it had to be July of 8180 Black
Sabbath with Ronnie James Dio Sammy
Hagar before Van Halen and somebody else
Philadelphia I had never seen this
before my [ __ ] whole life at the age
of 17 18 they were spitting on their
fingers and would clam on their fingers
and flick the fingers spit at you I was
in sixth row at Black Sabbath and the
first five rows were just people
spitting on their fingers and fling it
at Sammy Hagar Sammy Hagar's on stage
[ __ ] evade and spit okay so I put all
these things together in my head that
you can't sing in Philly the football
didn't they hit somebody with a battery
at a football game yeah there was a one
of the Dallas Cowboys I thought he hurt
his neck I think it was maybe jus
Pierson at number 88 I don't give a [ __ ]
and he [ __ ] it was a like a [ __ ]
and they started throwing [ __ ]
batteries at the guys they're carting
them off like they booed [ __ ] Santa
Claus the granite that was like December
15th Santa Claus only Santa Claus one
day a year that's December 25th so that
guy was just a fat guy in a red suit
rooting for the wrong team they [ __ ]
voodoo butter but I mean they're
notoriously [ __ ] horrible why else
would you put a jail like they're
consistently number two
worse fans in every sport nobody it's a
scrape it's with dice tape is special
yeah
which if they love you bro they love you
they laugh that's why I love going every
yeah I go to every year yes was it the
heaven in outdoor yeah
August 9th of 1980 yeah August 9 they
they spit at him did when Ronnie James
Dio took the stage they were boredom
[ __ ] security couldn't even control
you we did it that's where the my buddy
in fact we got to the show with like
shitty tickets
that was like a whole [ __ ] day we got
to the show with shitty tickets my buddy
left and came back with men addicted he
finagled 18 throw for six rolls Santa
and then he came back with these
quaaludes that weren't really quaaludes
they were these long purple things like
a dog much fun with yeah you know it was
acid he came back with these big ass I
know it was like I'm a little Martian I
was somebody spray-painted purple I know
that's not acid he kept saying I'm
telling you it's acid he'd take a two of
them and during the show he passed out
so on the drive home we have to tell
them those are purple quaaludes and he
was pissed I'm telling you those weren't
quaaludes
actually they were acid then why the
[ __ ] did you pass out yeah this so for
years every time he come to me and go
shoe butts got the best coke or
something he go you know it's got good
coke we I go weren't you the guy did the
purple quaaludes in Philadelphia he'd
never look [ __ ] you it was telling you
that was the best asset ever did they
pencil shavings and they'd sell to dudes
for like you know and it's real good
Weed Man it's like Mexican rubber there
was pencil shavings and he's taking
stupid kids would buy because they never
know what [ __ ] pot look like and I go
you ripped it you get ripped off again
you idiot talk I remember being in
Philly and snorting coke
we had the trunk open for that black
saboteur on the trunk in those days you
put coolers in your trunk yeah and you
went to a concert you tailgate it the
same way you tell we hit the trunk open
yeah we had the two coolers out get your
free show buzz on
we had the car stereo on heaven in hell
we're hanging out
little bottle we were the plan was to go
to Philadelphia and then drive to
Seaside Heights and spend the night on
the way back that was the plan
so I'd had one of those little brown
bottles filled with coke to the [ __ ]
brim the next thing you know [ __ ] car
pulls up and the see FBI and they throw
something else the car and they go
through our [ __ ] and that bottle was in
that tub it was in plain sight they were
looking for bootleg t-shirts cuz people
were selling bootleg t-shirts back there
and there's gonna looking for the FBI or
some [ __ ] [ __ ] there mr. Brell Ramon
they didn't touch that little [ __ ]
bindle of death it was one little bottle
with the spoon at the top oh yeah yeah
yeah you get all one man out of man what
a bad bro was a guy with the bass drum
and a cymbal on things or oh yeah it was
a one man thing then they sold the kits
they sold them open up the kids yeah and
the kid was like a wallet Lee it came
like a wallet Green it was like an
off-color ground probably you flip it up
then there was a green thing right and
there was the scale that was tiny yeah
it was accurate as [ __ ] yeah bro those
things with little scale was a big lamb
to know that every branch where they had
a [ __ ] and a little alligator clip on
the end of it you put on the thing and
you'd hold it off his thumb and it went
way down like it was just so that was
the weed one yeah yeah that was the one
that was the weed one it was a weed one
that you put on your thumb and then hung
down and it would be perfect and you put
the button it and it would weigh surface
yeah and then they came up with the
green one the one that was compacted you
put in your pocket and you took it out
and you could wait coking it and put it
at whatever it was good for a balls
great they had a digital readout on my
gran was I'm pretty good I never got for
the digital down at that one and then we
robbed the high school and we robbed the
science lab we took all the triple beam
scales I was like a big shot I teach you
how to come to my house listen you gotta
give a couple of them back like they cut
a deal with us eh you keep dirty but you
got to give us 30 back you can't leave
us without triple [ __ ] we were walking
out of there every day without without
with a triple beam scan
on Sunday I don't what am i walking up
went to high school with took all the
trouble beam scales two days later camel
breath george megrath one of the [ __ ]
crazy teaches by the list man now just
give us after scale i had a show but
everybody had those triple beam scales
the [ __ ] down no everybody had a
scale at the house lee how crazy is that
the eighties of you didn't have the
scale you were like come out kazakh if i
want the scale okay it's in the back
room there's a set this famous story it
was like it was what was at one time
we're at the back in crest hill base and
there's this guy named magic this middle
east to do there used to be like you
know it was two dad wouldn't be able to
dig sam stuff and you know it's like
it's kind of like a deal his name was
man i watch this guy one time you know
what you is this this is like [ __ ] 89
but he was arab what's again remember
there was a lot of Arabs around no no so
if when I showed up he had to be really
cool the other show up with Diamonds
yeah Sam the Arab telling you some
basically all of the Arab in the
eighties so this dude this dude has a
bag but he takes his two fingers digs
him into the baby like warpage you have
the first time I've ever seen his
stomach oh this is gonna be a scene in
the movie he tears up it aged out of the
magazine like almost straight falls in
like the perfect triangle makes a bend
alone then he looks in the frickin bag
and he [ __ ] eyeballs he takes his two
fingers in he grabs a bit he looks at it
throws it in the freaking bindle you
know bit a little more like I this tiny
ball then like there was stuff on the
end of his finger did you like he's
folded up in yours here take like take
that take that over to simple it was
like he had an eight ball I never seen
anybody do that before in the front seat
of a car like go from like you know
breakout on the bag into the bindle into
the thing if I knew what was in the bag
I could iron a ball yeah and it could be
off 2.5 maybe yeah if I said what if I
knew I had seven in the bag
I can I laid well yeah if I knew I had
fourteen like an iron 8-ball
you know I could I get high you can be
pretty much I yeah I get high take some
road that was a young kid I was like you
know I probably like me 26 or 27 I saw
that guy do that you go champ
that's amazing how long have you been
doing accommodate for now Jesus probably
started and I started feeling it's like
coming up on 30 30 years yeah but I know
you don't dumb back in Philly over no I
don't know gone back and filler there's
a couple I knew Keith Robinson back in
Philly and it taught glass back in
Philly and like you know those were the
kind of guys kind of started with you
know some and uh yeah but I only I did
comedy for about two years of Philly I
was gonna go to New York and I said well
I don't know you are conventional gonna
have to go to LA anyway and I go get
this you know and I and I because I've
been you know been performing like you
know basically like my whole life I was
doing [ __ ] magic when I was 11 and 12
I've got like three or four shows I'm
hopeful they'll bring it up some won't
so that and then I went to bed 18 I just
went the club for a couple years and
headed out this way that's cuz I knew I
was going if I went to New Yorkers gonna
have to go to LA anyway so I just said
let me just skip out the middle men's go
to LA and then I started working at the
showcase from it's you like two weeks
later I didn't pass but I got a job at
the doorman the night they hand the
night that Tony Clifton was supposed to
appear to man was like a year after Andy
Kaufman's deaf and I mean Tony Clifton
is appearing at the main woman to Comedy
Store and everybody thought oh [ __ ]
and he it was a character Andy Kaufman
used to do this Tony Clifton guy they
thought any Kaufman was like year afters
that they thought it was gonna be and
that was the day I started working as a
doorman and needed extra people because
it was crazy and it was really Bob zmuda
dressed as Tony Clifton because so but
all the media thought it was Andy
Kaufman playing a joke on him and he
went up there and it strike him I've
never seen him like everyone stays like
probably 15 20 we'll start walking
people
he's flitting like cigarettes and people
throwing drinks at people his character
Tony Clifton was a [ __ ] nut bag
empties the [ __ ] room out and as
people were walking out like well we
felt like you know was this hilarious
but ever since then I started working at
the door and then eventually we got past
as unlike a non-paid regular I could did
the belly room so probably like you know
86 87 you know was where I started
that was big when Bob zmuda I never got
all that I by the way no I never did
either I was your Andy Kaufman used to
do this character and then a man when he
would do it like about halfway through
doing the character Andy Kaufman do it
he gave the character to Bob zmuda and
said you do and he caught you do and he
said you
Tony Clifton from now on you just here's
the thing because they were dressed up
it was a big deal you know everybody
knew that Andy Kaufman was doing that
character they didn't realize he'd
handed it off for him to to so a year
after his death when Tony Clifton's make
an appearance at the main room at the
Comedy Store everybody thought this is
where Andy's gonna [ __ ] this is where
he's going to tell everybody didn't
really die they thought he was playing a
joke on so but it was [ __ ] crazy and
it was insane that's like you know
nothing but Bob zmuda
to this day continues to do the Tony
Clifton character which is where he does
it around town he does I've seen him at
flappers I've seen him I've seen him do
it in Chicago at the one of the Chicago
comedy festivals I mean he's just I mean
that's not like a big thing because most
people don't remember Andy Kaufman used
to do the character it's way beyond like
like you should drop that like years ago
but he still does it I mean it's it's
the stupidest thing like you know it's
just like at one point it was good he
would actually try to do a show but he's
been in the Comedy Store in the main
room he does Tony Clifton he has the
singing girls not recently but probably
like maybe two two years ago three years
ago he was doing it I mean you know
people you know people get the backstory
and they think it's kind of fun but most
people don't even know who [ __ ] Sam
Kinison was let alone who and even
though in decomp it's a big enough body
work most people look you know the
younger generation they don't have any
[ __ ] reference they don't like know
you know you gotta turn people on the
Sam Kinison they go back and look as
YouTube stuff the guy was [ __ ] great
they don't know now he's been dead for
26 years ago I got the Sam Kinison
foxhole I want to look up something on
young comedian special
oh yeah I watched Sam said and then
there was something from I watched
something else like a wall no one died
from how or something yeah and I was
[ __ ] how do you know but hey what
happened about an hour later I turned
off the thing where they take I look
like I sold or something must have been
11:30 at night I went back on social
media I checked my Twitter and the first
tweet that came up was hey how [ __ ] up
was Kennison at that taping in Vegas I
thought about how creepy is ish some guy
well I ran them on Twitter Wow
please II said wisdom I went to had the
Fox hold Louisa yeah I was the moon fat
kid do you don't even know how crazy
that was I mean he had scheduled three
[ __ ] shows dude he was like when we
did like we did the universal
Amphitheatre in fricken that show and he
had like Ginger Baker on the drums
he had c.c. Deville from poison [ __ ]
David Lee Roth was there I mean it was
like a [ __ ] music and then we all go
to the Van Nuys Airport jump on [ __ ]
weird jets fly to Vegas for like a 3
a.m. show I mean that was one of the
years he didn't but Kinnison also did
like he was 5 3 a.m. to a 3 a.m. show in
Vegas bro and but but that's the one
where Sam was so [ __ ] up his brother
bills doing a countdown from behind the
curtain Dan cuz his brother Billy Sam
was so [ __ ] up they didn't even want
to do the show but they you know they
got him on [ __ ] oxygen they got him
breathing and this is after like three
this isn't like staying up for like
three four days in a [ __ ] row like
you say your [ __ ] room service bill
is seventy five hundred hours for three
days just in booze and [ __ ] I mean he
did I mean believe me bro that was like
I mean that was it bro I did that that
one trip in Vegas I came back and I
started going to [ __ ] AAA meetings I
said I'm done I'm [ __ ] done bro I
mean I did I had to get a cat scan I
thought that brain damage that go today
and calmly no no it doesn't it can't go
I'm you know I'm glad that happened when
a dead bro because I mean Joey you now
[ __ ] look how hard you [ __ ] work
you can't do that [ __ ] you lose [ __ ]
three or four days how about I mean it's
not I told Lee that if I was still doing
coke we would have been here waiting for
me ten times yeah I mean it's not even
now would have been calling you go away
I'll be there in ten minutes
yeah it's just off dude we're just at
6:00 a.m. podcast we used to do yeah
it's insane and I think about it
sometimes right it's a get physically
ill when I think about the amount of
drugs it's just the [ __ ] people
hanging out the [ __ ] all these
[ __ ] like it was just kind of like
like creepy you know I mean our friend
Kinnison was my buddy man I got put
[ __ ] great moments in my life I get
to do the spectrum and Philadelphia open
forum for 6300 people I mean this guy
was [ __ ] you know I had a I just felt
[ __ ] bad for the
dude man you say you say you know like
you going to committees today are
prepared for success it's like nobody
wants to be that guy
it wouldn't [ __ ] play I mean looking
looking you know and God rest their
souls but Chris Farley's and and the
guys that you have John Belushi's and
kinnison's it's like he's my dad Burks
what's a Mitch Hedberg yeah I mean guys
that you [ __ ] what I mean just
needles it's nuts it's not enough to be
[ __ ] a great fun community you really
have to be prepared success when it
comes and just some of us are you know
to just taking solvus you know a little
longer than others I mean I learned I
had to learn how to become a
professional you have to learn how to do
these things and sometimes it's just you
know I mean I always think back on
printing condensing what would he have
done and I do the exact opposite it
usually works out I pick you know I've
gotta go how big fear was not getting
high because I wouldn't be funny I for
the last three years of my cocaine life
I was at struggle with myself yeah
because I like being that fat guy you
get a bunch of work but your doctor
tells you need to lose weight
yeah and you lose a hundred pounds and
you stop getting roles yeah you know the
fat guy no more yeah well the same thing
I was really concerned about if I stop
this cocaine they know that the funny
will not be there anymore that's part of
the whole craziness I thought that was
really ingrained and what fueled me yeah
so the fear that fear was what kept me
from stopping from maybe 2004 on I
wanted liquid cocaine well yeah but I'm
like I can't do well it's interesting I
mean I think you know you're such an
authentic human being I mean some guys
you know like like us I mean you
sometimes you there's two versions you
either [ __ ] drink and do the cocaine
the [ __ ] to fuel the fire or you
[ __ ] try to put the fire out with
using drugs and cocaine and sometimes
you know some guys as I mean I don't
know I finished the same way just the
unis had to come off it I just did I
just did enjoy who I was on it anymore
and I and and I think I wore out of gear
because you know you did that stuff they
just I just couldn't do it now I just
think I just all I just think of his
like all the [ __ ] time what do you do
after a show what is your ritual after
day night Friday night and Saturday
night show well usually I gotta get up
at 6 o'clock in the morning so I said
okay literally I really try to have a
really great show on Thursday night I
get you know and I mean you could have
six go to media so I go home right home
you know drink a bunch of water and get
up and do my media and just plan and
know like what I did on those shows
before us we try to do some new bits
about Friday night when you get this
Friday Friday - relax I just you know I
smoke reefers you do as an actor you do
what a pop cookie yeah I do I would do a
pot cookie that would put cuz it kind of
helps me sleep that's why I really do it
I mean I would do uh and then and then
just get ready for set food for me it's
all about working on that on the
material now the high for me is good
doing great you know come up with some
new bits and that gets me excited more
than anything is come up with a new bit
that kills me I got in the new 20
minutes in the front of my act and I
just I just kind of got working I mean
the first Benny kamat gets around them
applause and the second bin the third
and I'm excited about that I can't
witness how do you feel about that today
like we had this [ __ ] stupid excuse
it was a [ __ ] excuse Ted oh yeah well
what a comical performer gets offstage
yeah they're adrenalin they they have to
keep the high going it was this [ __ ]
[ __ ] I bought into also I'm not
gonna lie to you
yeah but I'm gonna be bunk that [ __ ]
right now yeah first off yes you need to
need something to take that edge off
when I come off stage and I have a great
set I'm ready to fight somebody yeah I
want to stab somebody in the [ __ ]
wall yeah and then you talk to your
peers behind stage a little bit and you
go out and take pictures or whatever and
then you go back to your room and your
mind starts racing you know for me my
mind starts racing that's why I bring
the vapour with me yeah
I roll the extra joint when I get back
to the hotel yeah you know because
that's my night to be loose yeah I love
my Friday night tell me my Friday night
family I don't have to get up yeah the
next time yeah you know I don't have to
do [ __ ] no all I know is I gotta beat
that hotel breakfast by 11:00 that's
right
I can make it down there my 11 eat that
first all I need is even if I go to bed
at 4 I'll be walking around at night and
get up in management cup of coffee in my
room yeah I hit the vapor better get the
appetite dog
yeah I roll a joint
sometimes I wash my [ __ ] sometimes when
I want a dirty [ __ ] I just watched my
hand put some monkey juice on it and tap
my pipe of ice and in my eyes I eat that
breakfast downstairs
two eggs the two slices of bacon on
piece of weak toast yeah a cup of
oatmeal
I go around for a walk around the name
but I blast that [ __ ] number and I go
back upstairs and I put on some on
narcos yeah until I feel a little tired
I take that nap till 2:00 and I'm good
yeah so that hold the bulk of the wool
we need to keep the party alive that's
just an excuse now I know it's [ __ ]
ex-junkie I lived off it so I could tell
you when I go back into the green room I
take a couple of [ __ ] deep press and
I let it [ __ ] go I mean that's the
biggest thing I do is let go of that
[ __ ] energy from the show because it
was [ __ ] show just kind of calm down
go out there get a nice buck big bottle
of water or maybe I maybe I have a drink
one drink and then get the [ __ ] out or
say I take pictures and get the [ __ ] out
and I'm not about keeping the party
going again gonna do stuff I think I
mean like you know you had those nights
where you like [ __ ] knocked back like
four or five drinks you lose the next
two days you know you sleep in a little
bit I guess I can't I can't afford it
anymore you know well then like you said
it's not taken care of so the recovery
time the recovery Tolleson I couldn't
handle and always when I was 35 yeah
exactly
I was already puking blood I would go to
that [ __ ] Miami wet willies and I
drink those red drinks does Jenner's to
caulk a bollock at [ __ ] up oh you know
I saw
deuces hey David area David Elliott
Merrill's how are they though dude the
murrow's boys are great things you know
I was in West Palm like thought about
them the whole time
man there's such good guys dude I was
just down there hanging with him we had
that we had lunch they're good they're
paradise paradise porno tell brother
those guys with it there's I mean those
two guys are great like they're from the
old school but there's 20 years and they
still haven't made that movie and
and they've spent millions they got
millions those two [ __ ] they both
walk around squeaking those you brothers
they [ __ ] vocalist one plays tennis all
day the other one quit smoking pot yeah
so now he don't smoke pot no no he was a
[ __ ] big pot and I mean the moment
you win the Paradise Point was a hotel
and uh yeah South Beach yeah but they
still have it they everything but they
you know the rules that's a very low key
but they like you said they live like
doctors are they white doctors and West
Palm I think the fall that they invented
the tennis racket is [ __ ] you know
and there were just these two sweet
brothers they were tremendous I mean
yeah there was a time where like you
know there hung out what those guys are
to carry it oh my god what the I would
stay in Miami they give me a room the
hotel for free that you could walk to a
bodega where they were at there's a
movie called Empire one of the worst
movies you'll ever see yeah it's got
John Leguizamo and a couple other people
holding Madonna's husband's in it
it's a it's an interesting movie if it's
late night you buy yourself and that HBO
but the scene where he goes to Miami to
shoot the guy and he meets a guy and he
thousand the guy told him to spit the
gum out of his mouth and he goes why he
goes put the gun under the piece of the
table the guns waiting for you
it's like me calling you long ago in the
Philly and the piece when I get there
I'll see your Mimi and this bodega that
bodega was walking distance from
Paradise Point and they sold you my food
by the pound Lee you have no idea I
would get [ __ ] up til 6:00 7:00 in the
morning get up at 10:00
and walk over to that [ __ ] bodega
bodega that had tremendous Cuban food
and they would get one of those [ __ ]
containers like you get a chow Ling's
what's that [ __ ] Chinese restaurant
don't when you get the five different
orders yeah they will put black beans on
one rice pack of it oh yeah it was raw
with a side order of fried bananas the
two or three cans of coca-cola died
walked back to that hotel and I'd inhale
that food smoke a joint and go right
back to bed every room that has a
different theme yeah at the Pirates room
they got like the [ __ ] in that those one
was to see
all the sea creatures right that seem
sweet when all the room said to her own
team but they had like eight rooms yeah
yeah and dude do I have a rooftop patio
a rooftop during the season all the
models that were down there shrine it
would stay there so they all these
beautiful girls you're skinny hot sexy
you're right here moms look around there
and then every afternoon be a roof in
the part and then a really good turn
they go up the route party montrezl
which thing is you know plays music he's
met mantra as well those black singers
that were main white girls [ __ ] Oh
crazy yeah you can bring out the panic
oh my god my eyes is [ __ ] brilliant
yeah your eyes he spray so you don't it
still lives in the basement I think yeah
they still go I'm living in the office
montrezl is one of those guys that fell
between the cracks and it happens in
comedy yeah it happens in music and it
happens all the time because just
something didn't click yeah well it's
it's like anything else I mean you know
it's oh yeah you're right it happens
that you see all that stuff you see with
music you see with bands is for me you
know
Tommy combo and the young world was has
been a [ __ ] Saint much oh you know he
could sing he still can sing you know a
couple weeks ago I'd do a thing about my
first ten years of comedy I came on the
podcast and wrote it out I really
thought about it because I just wanted
people to know what you need to go
through you know I went through the
first three years where I would just
tell people I was a comic I got on stage
once every two weeks yeah I would
improvise I'd ever get cereal and then I
finally fell in love with it and I
attacked it and then they moved away and
I felt bad afterward because I reluctant
mention you one time this is why I'm
having you know the podcast late to
apologize to you because there's nobody
who will help me out when I got here
more than you
oh really like yeah like I remember
talking to a certain comic up at the
store one night and I don't know how you
and me connected and you said don't talk
to him he's a [ __ ] loser and then at
that time you had just gotten yet your
first deal when you came back from
Montreal yeah I forgotten BC came up to
you yeah I mean you hooked me up with
your manager
I just spoke to the other day Jeff
Keller who I lost who I loved dearly you
taught me the ropes you even gave me a
briefcase to take my notes and notebooks
on the road with me and I just recently
threw away when I moved to the valley
because it was such a beat-up suitcase
yeah it was my brother it had so much
tradition you know I get but you had put
10 years into it it was like a suitcase
to have your headshots and resumes
because you don't want to take it your
books because you're coming out here you
know people don't get us like it's a
real like kind of like when you're out
on the road you're traveling you're
tourists like playing college ball but
when you get to LA and even know a ton
[ __ ] it it's really kind of running with
the pros you know you're gonna have
auditions and you're gonna have [ __ ] you
go this isn't a [ __ ] game anymore
and you're competing some of the best
people looking you just gotta have your
[ __ ] [ __ ] together a little bit no
you fooled me and I want to thank you
scientist my pleasure
I remember you you would taking acting
classes on Mondays at The Improv with
that dude who was like a high-level
acting coach yeah he was jerk with
committing specific right I want to say
Krakauer yes Bob Krakow I'm got me I
that guy you know was in an acting class
who it was Jeff channa
it was Jimmy Fallon it was me it was
Kathleen Madigan and was like you know
there were some uh there was some [ __ ]
Todd glass was I'm in some heavy weight
like [ __ ] comics at a time and he who
specifically work with comedians and
trying to do that book everything with
that was I love Bob Krakow because he
was he got what you did he goes and I
would work on like fine audition I could
work with him in class and then go do it
later on
amazing him and the woman named Karen
West I mean you know look I got little
parts here I got bigger parts I got some
but you know people don't realize it
collectively you get that [ __ ] money
from Sean and you get residuals and you
get your insurance and you get to [ __ ] a
bank at a credit union you get benefits
from the [ __ ] union that didn't get
what [ __ ] stand-up and so I was
always like yeah I gotta keep my [ __ ]
fee because I was funny back that I
learned that from you yeah when I by the
time our crew our paths cross I had
already realized that I was not gonna
get any love as a staff the stand-up
cards were not not at that time
Montreal didn't want me he applause
didn't want
I gotta find my manager I did I couldn't
find an agent I mean it just
and you had books you had book go yeah
you had just begun and I just want you
to go come on lady not $99.99 you know
then I was so I was hanging which is
awesome yeah yeah we were I was having
already before then I booked that
[ __ ] wrong I mean I just got back
from the parent my 12 year old cousin
Joe Casey he passed away and I wasn't in
the [ __ ] mood for the Hollywood
[ __ ] and I went in and and I had a
couple auditions that day and they
called me back for nineties [ __ ]
through and I just [ __ ] did my thing
like really brought food a chair down I
kicked the [ __ ] chair a couple times
I was like I supposed to [ __ ] freak
out I just [ __ ] turn around I just
walked out in the [ __ ] joint and you
know get Lennar amigo calls me and he
goes you're in first position for that
[ __ ] movie went big deal because I
was still in the middle of doing a
[ __ ] development deal thing I was
trying to get a [ __ ] TV show on so I
didn't give a [ __ ] about that movie go
was a [ __ ] brilliant [ __ ] cult
classic I just work with doug liman the
guy who directed that but it was like I
mean I mean it came in a really [ __ ]
shitty point and I but I got the role
and I was like that's what I started to
realize but yeah I mean you know you you
don't realize it could mean you can
still get these things if you can
audition well you can get them you know
yukky and so directors you got the deal
first I hung with you I met you when you
were in the process of the deal and
trying to find him go to hoist walk you
know why me lunch a noise walk right on
sunset LaBrea we would smoke a joint
we'd go back to your house and then you
also discovered that I was the real deal
when I called the the quarterback that
we were I was mad man my drive ever
I made my [ __ ] Chile I had the world
class yeah you were watching the game
and you were calling the place the place
Johnno was gonna run this thing in a
Monday night oh my god he was called and
and that was the play where he jumps in
he gets hit in the back and spins around
you rent landed I go watch the hallways
and I run this it yeah I was calling the
play because I knew Denver so well it
was like even hot I was watching Denver
for years I was there when Elway got
drafted I was there yeah
well against Cleveland when he made the
drive against Cleveland I knew our way
like the back of my
yeah I knew that he had a get the right
team dude I know I did I do football and
you were like three player this
[ __ ] I knew I do that
illegitimate I knew them by this time
yeah I was wide cuz you're my god you
used to collect book or watch her yeah
booth for them so I would watch I would
watch the Broncos till the end
yeah always you know I still remember
when they won their first championship
II I cried yes I always knew it Elway
was a winner when I heard that story
about how the Yankees went [ __ ] the
guy went into the his demeaning and
Steinbrenner opened up the cabinet and
left field was out what yeah I don't
care about [ __ ] football that's my
team two years I want John Elway cuz
I'll wait that then in this baseball
player for the Pope baseball players so
if nobody really knows the story it's
very interesting there he could sign
them sandy there was a scam oh they
scammed everybody they scammed everybody
first of all was the biggest football
draft ever for quarterbacks it was out
way Marino Boomer Esiason
it was like a big [ __ ] draft and
[ __ ] you gotta watch the 3430 because
I'm not giving it any justice right
Elway got drafted by the Baltimore Colts
that's watch and he didn't wanna play
football can when he's am I gonna
Baltimore so Steinbrenner cut a deal
with him Steinbrenner goes listen I'll
give you a half a mil give me a portable
no back you say you play baseball
I send you up to [ __ ] up there for a
couple months just play baseball for a
few months we'll forget about this whole
thing and then I'll sell your Denver it
was like a kinky deal but how way the
rumor was without waked step now we
could step on the warning track with his
left foot and without moving put it in
the catcher's mitt that was that was the
room that Elway could get a ball and
just [ __ ] launch it and put it right
the catcher's mitt that was how good
Elway was but he couldn't hit he was
phenomenal his arm was great he could
field something he couldn't had on
another exact story so that's what they
did it was a scam Steinbrenner back in
June and he was
Stein brother did not take [ __ ] from
anybody he got involved he got [ __ ]
what's his name
got him on there yeah he'll take
yourself one he got him on the [ __ ]
team they did something and then the
Broncos picked him up and that's how the
Broncos ended up with John L and John
Elway got tortured from day one and then
they didn't like him because every
football town yeah and then they started
winning but then he'd lost four Super
Bowls so by two Super Bowls or three in
a row they got killed against the
Redskins the only black quarterback to
ever go bananas yeah once against him
[ __ ] compete those racist and then we
were going crazy Oh Doug Doug Doug oh
that's a play from Washington yeah jeez
I know you're talking about you never
play football again oh yeah you never
got the KKK showed up but whatever the
deal is by Elway did one boat I'll go
two years to Doug Williams was his name
yeah but the handle bay buccaneers and
they went bananas on the Broncos that
guy never played again they went to his
house the next day and you ever play
football again you embarrass my people
yeah you destroyed white people we will
never [ __ ] let you play football
games he's coaching [ __ ] high school
football in the witness relocation
League there you think I'm [ __ ] you
well you know I love I love the l way
towards the end of his career wins
back-to-back Super Bowls oh he was a bad
look but that's what I'm saying like
you'll never get there no no but also
love that he also got with Peyton
Manning and got him to go out way got
around and win enough good players and
he got a second ring on his way out and
I mean he wasn't that Peyton Manning of
years before but always do had to manage
the game because that defense was
ridiculous but I loved that he got the
second Super Bowl ring playing with you
know Doug Elway is the you know we're in
the front office of that team the desire
to golf on the [ __ ] whatever but it's
true I know because of you I got into an
acting class because of you I did what
you said
you know three out of ten comics I'm
gonna have a pension yeah three out of
ten comics walk around with no insurance
yeah you know three because they never
really thought of the acting side no I
didn't want to be an actor I didn't
start off to be an actor
but I thought it would be a valuable
tool in my tool shed yeah I knew that
somewhere or another it will help me on
stage all makes you better stand up make
sure better stand up when you act and
then comes today when you incorporate
your stand up and do your acting yeah
now you're acting it becomes a [ __ ]
like I don't do a lot of things I don't
[ __ ] good I may not be able to cook a
[ __ ] steak but I will tell you what
I'm very good at is going into a room
yeah with four people
and [ __ ] them up yeah and it's
because of the original I give that
credit to the original room and cold
reading workshops yeah you combine that
together and you got something special
you have some anybody custard I look at
all the roles I've done I got a lot of
[ __ ] roles and it was just going in
straight up auditioning I didn't know
anybody I didn't have a [ __ ] famous
uncle I didn't have a famous dad I mean
you had to go in with 380 other [ __ ]
actors and do the best [ __ ] reading
you could the competition side of that
got me [ __ ] excited I mean there was
a there was a there's about six months
me and Billy Gardell
if I didn't get the job he got the job
if I didn't get the job he got the job I
got the job he didn't get the job but
from six months we were going for the
same stuff and then one time we're just
coming around a corner Warner Brothers
and he comes around to go to the
Schubert oh my god now I don't but you
know that friendly competition makes you
better it gets you know I mean I mean I
didn't get I want to know if my friend
got it but I've been like you said that
that that acting Stein's ever I know I
knew when I first got here I cannot lie
to you or to the audience when I first
got here I had a mental competitive
naturally but to succeed I had to
eliminate people as competition yeah
making my comrades yeah because you
compete against yourself that's what I
brew usually I did four years was when I
get an audition I made as a cosmic karma
thing for me I will call somebody who
was my type and said did you get a call
for this and there we go no I did you
gave me a couple calls on your agent
yeah
even though I wanted
roll I would call people just for the
karmic energy that's great to let people
know that because you don't know what
they're looking for
I'm the same way you don't want to give
me the job don't give it to me give it
to Lee yeah you don't think you tell me
let's give it to the Agostino yeah you
don't wanna give it to the end of steven
let's give it to [ __ ] and Rogen you
don't give the Rogen let's give it two
inch cut yeah but you're gonna give it
to somebody in my family you gotta give
it to somebody you're gonna give it to
somebody in my family and that's how I
thought when I went into those auditions
I eliminate everybody
I got no competition in this town yeah I
don't I have no ill will to no comic
anything at all with you I always feel
when we get the special I just got up I
feel she cuz I hang out with Lee I just
got up that means I just got up my
friends winds are my winds come on you
have to have that out of tentative don't
in this town you're [ __ ] you when I
see you
we brought like a piece of fruit for the
inside I see you hey i giggle because i
know they have no future yeah they just
signaled out their own future themselves
yeah I told him one day these open mic
cuz you hang out with you go to lunch
with down to it I don't want you hanging
out with them because they don't know
what they're talking about and they're
hating the same way I hated at that
level yeah because of that level I hated
because you don't have what you want
there's frustration it's eight brought
on by frustration yeah now when I go for
an audition the first guy calls nick
tutorial Nick you're going out for his
pizza guy no I didn't you know I go I
would call if any Colonel I would call
another friend of mine yeah me and him
started together a mafia role I'd rather
you got if I don't get it yeah you know
I rather one of my friends get it so
absolutely that helps you as a Carmel
level yeah because you know what people
are worried so much about getting the
[ __ ] job they can't actually go into
the room and be like we have a good baby
because they're trying to give them
something what they think they looking
for you got to go in and not give a [ __ ]
about any of that [ __ ] all anything care
about what you do in the audition it
does not look I'm already going in look
if I get the job great if I don't find
what do I lose yeah Minneapolis yeah
yeah exactly and I'm glad I was meant to
put on this earth that's exactly acting
is a [ __ ] cherry on the sundae that's
right that's it's a cherry on the sundae
yeah so I don't give a [ __ ] if I get it
or not it doesn't matter me I started as
a dirty copy that's right yeah every day
background music I know for a fat like
and I tell people this I don't want you
to be an actor yeah but I'm gonna stand
up I just want you to have the tools
yeah so if they do call you you don't
look like a [ __ ] Johnny jerk well yeah
and they will call and they will call
eventually somebody's gonna call you one
day you look like Johnny jerk-off
because you didn't do the work because
you didn't do the work I mean you're
gonna blame it on them and then beat
it's like when I first went to the South
to do comedy they don't like in the
Bible Belt they didn't like me in the
Bible Belt I'll never come back that's
what a loser says right a winner says
I'm gonna go back there and make them
love me yeah I got a sweat on my ass
like Elvis in Vegas right let them fall
in love with me first I can't go for the
finger bang yeah I gotta kiss him the
neck and tell him I love I love that
song he wrote that's I love when you
sing Bedford then you go for the finger
that's a it's like a [ __ ] finger bang
out but it's but it's you know and I
gotta tell you I've always feel
obligated they're like you know guys
coming out they don't get that I always
feel obligated because you know many
people did that for me like people
[ __ ] took me inside so you gotta do
this you gotta do this you gotta do this
you gotta do this and know all those
things and over the years this
cumulative help that people would give
you and I feel obligated to [ __ ] pass
them along to my friends the people I
think that were they have ability to
have talented you know like you said I'm
not I'm the lit last guy to get envious
or bitter or job mean I thought I don't
have it in my heart of the time I don't
have it in my heart man I wrote some
[ __ ] everybody I wrote more for the
guy on stage that he had you know
because it is mega new it's um there's
somebody that you know they put the work
and they've been doing it 20 [ __ ]
years I mean I think only another
comedian realize the the effort and the
tenacity and the [ __ ] grit and the
guts it takes to hang in there even when
you think it's all going wrong and still
believe in your stuff and still do it
and still bang it away and then you
[ __ ] look back and sometimes is our
smile I don't stop sometimes just
breathing I have to look all over but
wow look at all the [ __ ] you're able to
do look at all the study yes sometimes
you just stop and stop crying I just saw
a movie the other what's that I've been
thinking about you for a month
oh it's that - I saw you three times in
the matter of a couple of weeks
I saw you an open the Queen's right I
saw you I saw you mr. and mrs. Smith
yeah about two weeks ago when I go I got
call Shoob yeah who's two hundred
morning
you know time for a good call give a
fine yes sir I call you East Coast yeah
have you sleeping you sleep always
taking a punch that's great yeah I did
that freaking that American nightmares
on I was on Cinemax labs and now it's
one of the man but a people have no idea
Danny Trejo's and then when Cafaro was
being filmed
when goal was being cast yeah how much
heat that movie had already from the
script yeah
like when that script came out everybody
was trying to go out for the movie go
there's certain movies that come out in
this town everybody's trying to get
people know and every I mean everybody
was getting into go yeah
I'm still having a specific conversation
with a comic saying that he called the
managing office and a manager wanted to
sign him and then he gave them off to
made them I'll slide with you but you
got to get me in for go that's how big
people knew it was gonna be Scott wolf J
Moore yeah they hate even the young girl
that's cute [ __ ] she was dating doug
liman at the time Sarah Polley her pilot
Katie Holmes Katie Holmes a bill
Fichtner wasn't it the girl from Ally
McBeal the blonde girl was what's her
name she was on also on the 30 rock yeah
it had a [ __ ] amazing cast that ever
paid Diggs was in it you know there was
nothing was a big cast no English guy
from [ __ ] yeah last manescu that's math
skill was great I mean you know huh yeah
but Jimmy do file Jimmy Duvall who also
wound up being in the movie I did on
Cinemax well right now we do vow but he
was in it and yeah it was crazy man that
that kind of like really gonna really
kind of solidify didn't realize how big
that [ __ ] movie was it came out and
went against the matrix it's a cult
classic it made like 19 million over his
son I'm probably probably more now
worldwide but it was a great [ __ ]
ensemble cast to be part of the
doug liman he also put me in [ __ ] mr.
and mrs. Smith there for but I mean you
get these little [ __ ] jobs these
little things like you said dude well
the guy who played my dad screaming free
man I used to call
played the Dane in [ __ ] Miller's
Crossing was a [ __ ] yeah that guy was
the coolest [ __ ] like his old [ __ ]
marine and we were in his [ __ ]
trailer and he says you smoke pot yeah
smoke so we started we smoked little
buddy started giving me acting lessons
like you know we did filming over your
shoulder take your left eye you put it
against my left eye so open yourself up
to camera give me like five or six great
little [ __ ] cheats and I'm [ __ ]
hide anything are you guys ready for it
and it was just a pickup shot but it
freaked me out and ran out I rented
[ __ ] five movies just to look you
know all my favorite actors it's a study
of my [ __ ] and it goes and ever since
then ever on the movies that whatever
we're gonna high go they call it acting
lessons you wanna get some acting left
the [ __ ] martini shot but these guys
but he kind of took me under his arm and
kind of told me about these things we
worked up these scenes it was so great
to have a guy like that doing your first
big movie and the guys kind of giving
you all these little inside cheats on
how to be a better [ __ ] actor and
stuff did you think as a comedian you're
always kind of playing to the back you
know but film just registers thoughts so
you want to keep it tight no that was a
nothing scene I did but I never did
again for the rest of movies like I came
in there serious I had to work and I
said I would only do it after we get
done doing her it's really weird the
people we've like the guy that gave me
acting advice the first time ever and he
didn't give me bad advice I need just
[ __ ] touring to me about it was James
Coburn James Cole how [ __ ] weird is
that how great is that though James
Coburn oh that's old school [ __ ] though
that's cool as [ __ ] like I had to say
nothing to him I got that I shook his
hand Allan Stevens got me the job you
know James comer I shook his hand I he
don't nice to me trying to say nothing
because you want to run this once or
twice yeah let's run it once or twice we
did it I think I was look at my [ __ ]
hands because the other I throw this
[ __ ] and then we just [ __ ] rehearse
the scene then we would do it and while
we're doing it he said to me that I had
natural instincts like this is when they
moved the cameras around yeah you just
standing there like Johnny jerk-off yeah
you standing three feet from the [ __ ]
great advice [ __ ] on of all time
trying to keep it together she thought
he'd with Bruce yeah study modulated he
was honest Bruce Lee's mortars they
carried the casket I know you don't even
want to bring it up like the first dad
in st. look the first death is a nun I
took his advice because are you an
acting class I go yeag let's get the
[ __ ] out of because they're gonna ruin
your natural instincts well I go done
the hose you start with Jimmy DeStefano
at first yeah I'm a DeStefano remember
Jimmy I took a couple classes would you
be these two the first guy I signed what
was the guy that was very good he just
hated comedians because he had a bad
taste dice this guy was over on Gardner
and sunset and when he found that it was
a comic he worked me hard right and one
night I said to him what the [ __ ] is
your brother's he's under your job he
those I was one of the first guys to
ever work with and the dice clan he
[ __ ] me over
the movie made I'm making the grin or
whatever it was now the big one the
Cadillac one whatever the well I'll hide
it before family yeah something happened
what happened I so he was like [ __ ]
eight stand-up comic the class was on
Monday nights some Monday nights was the
hottest night that I ain't no star job
with Tina night The Laugh Factory and
the [ __ ] show at the improv freaky
Monday's how Marilla so I would always
have to do my scene and leave Frank
Magna that was my first acting teacher I
did not book anything with him I did not
get what the [ __ ] he was saying yeah
then I did a black guy that had HIV he
was over on dour in those blots yeah in
between sunset in Hollywood Boulevard
right some comic took me there but I
just thought of his face he's wait long
guy he's somewhere married right he took
me there to a class on Saturn I fell in
love with the guy that caught me that's
who I had when I got the callback with
Billy Gardell for the Travolta movie
right the one about the [ __ ] singer
right it was being Billy Gardell there
that morning or I was all coked up Oh me
and Billy is sitting there and it's a
director from Drugstore Cowboy and
Travolta in the room
and me and Billy had a read it was
either gonna be me and Billy Wow and
then they said [ __ ] it we'll make a boat
stand up Thomas so me and Billy work for
the same [ __ ] role and next thing you
know gallon goes you got this go to
Miami while I was in Miami I'll call
true Walter decided to do the
Scientology movie instead
oh wow so the kiss of Billy Gardell he
bit me in the ass that time cos Billy
was kicking ass at that time yeah Billy
had just booked four episodes that law
show oh yes all Sean NBC yeah yeah no he
was another black dude that wasn't any
good Billy Gardell was booking but
everything he booked was wrong for him
like it was just like a stretch of Billy
just said was having a hard time he was
booking but it would that he booked four
episodes that law and order you have
with y'all the show on ABC on Sunday
nights that was huge I think I built the
studio down in Orange County you had to
go down on him Beach to audition down
the block from Boston Market
they only shot four shows down there he
had so many SH he was married to
Michelle Pfeiffer somebody Oh David yes
he had so many shows going on at the
time yeah yeah he just told ABC I'm not
leaving I Lincoln Beach ya know the
studio they were all for sure so they
wouldn't shoot no Forbush shows that Wow
what's his last name David Lee maybe
David something yeah but you're right he
was he was right he's right now Lee
McBeal right shows a war dog he was
rocking it yeah and he shot his show out
then I'm never forget that that was the
same week that I was going as the spine
I went all week I would go down and I'd
see Billy guard uncle Gard [ __ ] damn
it but they were looking for three
different mobsters four different
mobsters so we all had a shot right it
would sound like the turn a score but
[ __ ] Billy Budd oh that's good though
it's good no but it wasn't a competition
yeah like [ __ ] the kisses death is here
business at the time Billy was to kiss
at that everything he [ __ ] was in
would get cancelled Wow it was always a
bad roll Billy shot before Billy got
that show on CBS don't he was unlucky
luckily I know the other John Anthony
Clark and the Anthony Clark show we
didn't like [ __ ] probably like 13
episodes of that show with Anthony Clark
and Mike Mike Mike Michael malli Mike
O'Malley they were in that show before
King and queens on CBS yeah he had a
billion always had a great [ __ ]
career acting like her Molly he's done
he was in the you know he's the during
the Jersey Boys and he's you know those
works a lot Billy gets it you know great
kid to happen to a better [ __ ] god
yeah no question about he was struggling
for a long everybody is until you get
those first couple breaks Institute I
was doing La Jolla listen that's what
I'm doing [ __ ] La Jolla
I'm gonna call Saturday at 5 p.m. can
you do this [ __ ] a movie from our boy
Rick Bronson who runs the [ __ ] clubs
you gotta go shoot me I got this
director he needs somebody he's in them
he's in [ __ ] Idaho Idaho Falls did you
shoot that dude yes you were supposed to
get it you couldn't do it do it
so they West Palm Beach Sunday they call
you Friday how grades this so he calls
me Saturday and says can you be on
playing on [ __ ] Sunday I flew up
Sunday and they [ __ ] got to get the
hotel the plane ticket everything's
right
I'm [ __ ] all day shooting with hyper
Penn Sean punch son in this [ __ ] move
it it's already had five or six offers
on it called poppy [ __ ] love the
director Michael Maxis is a great
[ __ ] guy we great guys all this
[ __ ] stuff and that scene frames the
movie it's in the beginning movie it's
all throughout the movies all these
little stories it's probably gonna
premiere in South by Southwest but that
was a role that you were supposed to
[ __ ] do they wanted you he goes
hauled me Friday he called you when he
called me Saturday ago I would have to
thank Joey did not being able to go as a
West Palm Beach they called me Friday
they made an offer Friday I thought
about it I go so when do you need me
they go Monday I had twenty things I'm
yeah no I'm just about to sell that show
the Fox yeah I come right there like I
had those meetings with writers Ida yeah
I had something and I had something that
Monday because when they first called me
they said we could shoot it Monday a
Tuesday little a this
there was something going on still like
no Monday's gonna be hard but Tuesday so
I would have had a flown from West Palm
all away
[ __ ] it's 11 pages of dialogue - it was
a [ __ ] it was a like a monster where
they were I was like [ __ ] I mean that
night I got there of Saturday
I flew in Saturday Sunday night and I
was just [ __ ] working on those lines
the whole thing and he was great about
it and he goes I guess you know you guys
I needed somebody never seen so I mean I
know it wasn't his first choice but it
didn't make a difference I got the role
I meant to that man - thank you for that
- how's it going you know it's it's a
[ __ ] man you know you it's the movies
already a kick-ass [ __ ] movie these
scenes were just reshoots for him so he
could get the [ __ ] because he wants to
[ __ ] premiere it and he's been
editing it for a year and a half with
Sean Penn in [ __ ] Michael Madsen
rosario Dawson where the life guy who as
far as compass is an amazing spectacular
life this guy's life is filled with
frickin you know yeah hookers and crack
pipes and [ __ ] all this [ __ ] in
another direction it's and puppy love is
such a just like such a [ __ ] him like it
doesn't but I'm telling you the guy is a
[ __ ] great movie director was great
to work with a Michael maxis and I think
this movie's gonna be a big [ __ ] deal
it reminds me of go it's the same kind
of vibe as like go but this guy and so
yeah with a plane to Utah another flight
behind the hole Springs where I got a
warrant
yeah and then I had to drive for an hour
well yeah
I'm like I don't know no I got a bad
back as it is plus the six hours from
west palm up yeah that would have been a
whole day of flying yeah dude I'm [ __ ]
old you know what it is when I had the
thing on Monday but I'm happy you got it
yeah I'm not talking about no I said I'm
saying I just did it was [ __ ] Karma
because it was like one of those things
cuz I you know I came at the right time
for me and I just yeah just [ __ ] yeah
you can what I got to lose
yeah I can do I get they let me out of
the show on a Sunday night at the lawyer
which they never used to do a Sunday
night show down there before but now I
guess they're cooking with gas so they
do third Friday Saturday Sunday show so
they let me out of it
[ __ ] I know Falls got the [ __ ] part
worked on all day
yeah hung out with liking Sean Penn's
kid hopper Penn we hung out went out for
drinks afterwards enough just jumped on
a [ __ ] plane flew to Philadelphia
where I did sparked the parks casino
that of Wednesday nights I literally had
that gap Sunday home alright is the park
this you know it's great it's great it's
right there but so I did it's not that
seven minutes for mom and dad's house I
bought you I said neighborhood roping
out there anything yeah did I love it
that was tremendous yeah that was I'm
going back next year yeah it's a crazy
long back they all made an offer I said
absolutely yeah like I loved I loved
everything about that yeah the drive
there everything was sensational cool
and you have a drive the guy took me
there for some cheese shake place and I
didn't even know yeah you get that was a
Steve Princess takes up there in front
of yeah yeah dude you're gonna take a
hot shower attached to one of the best
cheesesteaks ever it's right around the
corner from parks and it's like this
real gooey but they use the real like
cuts like like thin cuts and like prime
rivets like delicious like one of the
best best steaks I've ever had Steve
Prince of steaks which is about five
minutes from where I join in his Park
Casino tremendous no no I took right I
thought parks is you know that was where
I [ __ ] just got off the stage and went
into the audience they were that crazy
yeah like I didn't even go on the green
look a big fans Joey yet but nephews
let's do your friends getting crazy
they're crazy buddy Philadelphia's crazy
that's why I love it that's why I belong
there like whenever I know there I go
say some crazy [ __ ]
Negus i watch eleanor on stage talking
about getting fingers on the Morty's
pier I almost puked you would laugh
Azhar yeah with more these piers I would
stand a while in the church everybody
goes down destroy second one of those
things is like you know it's a it's like
Sun Goes Down and sure everybody went
down to Wildwood New Jersey for the
summertime you come down there you know
my grandmother would pawn her jewelry
she could get enough money so we go down
the [ __ ] shore for two weeks as kids
and we were going down there and spend
time in like you know long port or
fucking's always before these beers or
these piers Wildwood yet so you know
down why wouldn't you know all those
[ __ ] you know all those freaking Wow
[Music]
it's like part of Philadelphia culture
the mummer's scrapple all that
philadelphia [ __ ] soft pretzels [ __ ]
wild woods every bit a part of that goes
down a Paul Walker plane plane plane a
shoot shoot he shoots for a quarter I
gotta say [ __ ] a case of shame but I
really drinking shame for beer like you
know when you were a kid growing up and
the boardwalk and all that [ __ ] comes
flooding back and she got fingered
bagged underneath Morty's pier she said
that had lost my [ __ ] how funny is
[ __ ] on Laura Kerrigan dude she's
[ __ ] rock it was a success story
I loved it did I love that she you know
I mean she's [ __ ] really tremendously
[ __ ] how much to watch a girl from the
waitress is a comedy store if I could
doing a WWE and the stuff and actually
go up on her for dice now strong she's
become as a as a comedian Ellen's like a
[ __ ] sister to me man I [ __ ] love it
I left she says she's a sweetheart she's
got a heart of gold with all her success
yeah me too I mean I but I mean she I
just love watching someone like her get
so [ __ ] good and so funny and she's
[ __ ] mine a follower once I were you
working with me in La Jolla she just
[ __ ] slaughter she suddenly did I
love it I love it did she mean you
believed 30 years you doing this I know
that's a [ __ ] dirty what five thirty
no 30 [ __ ] years 30 years but I make
a living what affectional I mean it
could have gone either way I could have
gone I would have doves up my ass and
out my sleeves I could've go to the
magic but I want in the [ __ ] comedy
that I'm like you I feel this is exactly
where I'm supposed to be I mean I love
making a room full of people [ __ ]
laugh well there's a thousand people or
two hundred people or fourteen [ __ ]
people I don't give a [ __ ] I love it I
love being able to create comedy I'll be
able to take control room and just make
people laugh so that they [ __ ] piss
themselves I mean there's nothing better
than that I mean you know I'm you know
people come on come up to you and go
they grabbed me by the your arm and I
haven't [ __ ] laughed like that and so
long I [ __ ] needed that I mean you
know I never take that for granted I
[ __ ] I just to be able to do that is
a [ __ ] gift and to be able to touch
people and move people with your [ __ ]
jokes and something you created and
write comedy and you don't know there's
somebody in the audience or thinking
about killing himself maybe they lost
her favorite aunt maybe something's
going on in life and they come in
they're sitting funny or in front of for
45 minutes you get to make them laugh
and before you know it they forget about
all that [ __ ] and
we're going goddammit that's real power
and it's healing and it's [ __ ]
everything I [ __ ] love and I just did
it just feeds my soul and I believe I'm
exactly what I'm supposed to be doing
making people laugh
Jimmy shoe but I feel in my heart you
are the 10 top comics working today god
that's [ __ ] insane I see this and
that brought all the confidence in my
heart I could tell you that because I
know what you've been through you know I
watch these guys I think this is a
fly-by-night business nobody pisses me
off more on these fly-by-night comics
they can pick nominee for all the wrong
reasons
yeah you know you're a guy that this
disparity is gonna take every year how
it comes and I get better and better
with ya ya ya know imagine don't imagine
doing this the 30 [ __ ] years you're
gonna get good at it then eventually you
do the same move for dirty is hammer and
nails done you're gonna get really good
at the same you watch and [ __ ] you and
I remember I'm remember all the [ __ ]
old nights the [ __ ] original room and
[ __ ] you know and watch you go up
there and [ __ ] annihilate bro you are
the most authentic [ __ ] voice in
front I did I watch you do the [ __ ]
just [ __ ] slaughtering you're [ __ ]
hilarious you're authentic you were true
to who you are and you're doing it's the
same thing man it's like [ __ ] you
watch guys who put the time in and pay
the dues and you just come man it's
[ __ ] amazing feel about getting food
well I got booed at a buffalo hockey
game of all the [ __ ] places that get
booed with a hot you know it's it's it's
those things that you remember forever
yeah I don't madtv was a great
experience for me yeah do I wrote like a
badge of honor though I did two episodes
all right I tell you what I wear that
bombing and Buffalo like a badge of
honor because it made me who I am today
yeah those bombings those beatings they
either take you out of the game too or
you come back with a little beef
sandwich with horseradish on my dick and
call me shorty they're gonna [ __ ]
handle people by 10,000 people a fry
funk of mom and dad in my hometown it
was like [ __ ] it lifting the cattle
off the [ __ ] Shaolin Temple and now
you can lean because there's nothing
you're ever gonna do to me in the
[ __ ] comedy room or a comedy place or
anything that [ __ ] that was as bad as
[ __ ] that getting booed your [ __ ]
hometown
friends like guy you can't do anything
to me in a [ __ ] comedy club that's
gonna hurt me like that because I'm not
[ __ ] nothing
I got [ __ ] six brothers my old man
was a homicide and take them I got one
feeling and I [ __ ] dare you to hurt
it it's like you know I mean well you go
through you do you wear those things on
the badge of honor it's like I can't you
can't do anything to me as I get you
know it's but it but it's great you got
to get those those it's like you said
all those all those worst nights and
there are the things that build up your
[ __ ] you know maybe like you said you
sort of bet I mean all the winds are
great too but still you know those
bombings are great especially you come
on you shouted flappers yeah last year
yeah shadow the about a year and a half
ago and you know we had that like you
want to pose for it to it a color
correction I I financed the whole thing
myself I did the whole [ __ ] thing top
to bottom myself I got the guys who
shoot it we went in there we hung
curtains hung lights I just want to go
in there and we shot it in 4k it's
called zero tolerance and it's a [ __ ]
straight up [ __ ] our a [ __ ]
stand-up comedy we could come up with a
cool little opening for I really like
the opening yeah the opening is just a
[ __ ] like you know it's like in this
day and age like the things people get
[ __ ] upset about now it's like you're
overreacting to all this [ __ ] that's why
that kind of like defuses the bomb you
know you're yeah it was being censored
by social me and and over sensitized as
being expurgated by the political
correctness beliefs it was like that
that opening is just like yeah
[ __ ] its comedy man I mean Jesus dude
I was watching Rodney Dangerfield on
like an old YouTube thing and what that
rotted Dangerfield rabbit-hole and I go
man if this what the [ __ ] was alive
today we know he's fat shaming people I
mean we could you couldn't even [ __ ]
be Rodney Dangerfield of that I mean did
I [ __ ] it's just just funny like some
of the stuff you see like do you think
Kinnison could get away with the stuff
he was doing back then I mean it still
holds up but I mean just with the
climate and how sensitive people become
it's [ __ ] ridiculous
I'm 56 years old February 19th right if
you think I give a [ __ ] about your
feelings anymore yeah you got another
thing coming I'm gonna talk to you
what's in my heart you know it's so
[ __ ] weird that I don't give a [ __ ]
yeah I'm with you I don't and I ain't
apologize my brother
like [ __ ] you it's like you know the
thing that we love the most is gonna
kill us and that social media you know I
use social media for something
completely different
yeah I don't know about my political saw
it so I don't involve my views or my
opinions I involve what I'm thinking
yeah and I want you to think what I'm
thinking to them you want to make it you
today yeah you better [ __ ] go drink
some coffee
medicine take a right at him grab your
[ __ ] ball salute the flag yeah it's
gonna be a [ __ ] American go hustle
yeah well you're gonna sit there on your
ass and [ __ ] I don't want you around me
yeah I really don't there's a formula
and it works dude I'm [ __ ] wit work
yes it works it's all washing your [ __ ]
and getting out of the [ __ ] house and
do what you [ __ ] love until you figure
out how to make a buck doing it yeah and
if you don't want to do that then lay on
that couch and you could cry anybody the
[ __ ] house that's what I put on the end
Amore's I tell you my dates and I get
the [ __ ] out of it I don't need to take
a picture of celebrity I'll need to show
you my [ __ ] die I show you what I'm
smoking yeah cuz I want you to know what
the recipe is
smoke uncle Joey Diaz like now you get
these people that go to a comedy show
this to them listen social media and you
just become you know when I go on social
media on a Saturday just to look at the
climate yeah and I see those same people
tweet and I feel bad for them yeah I
feel bad for those people that tweet and
proposed on Friday I want you to get off
social media for Friday there's some day
yeah going wait if I'm in life gonna
live your life gonna love you look
awesome I suppose life yeah yeah my New
Year's I told them right up I go if I
was 30 years old could give this pinkie
up right now the Japanese Joe's for New
Year's yeah I give this pinkie up if I
go on New Year's Eve to a bar be
comfortable do two bumps and have three
beers and maybe take a xanax and go home
I would have done that I told I'll eat
do something you cannot stay lonely when
he made it cause some chick came over
some little victim yes mrs. balls and
the rest is history you understand
whether you like them or not but you
have to live your life yeah I mean
you know not be stuck all day well
people do this [ __ ] [ __ ] hashtags
that they act like to brave he was so
brave to hashtag it
I go [ __ ] go out and [ __ ] you know
I did on Christmas dude it's the first
time I've done this I went down to the
Laugh Factory I said those [ __ ]
almost people all [ __ ] afternoon cuz
I didn't have nothing to do I won't go
home to my fish I don't have kids going
through a [ __ ] break up I'm good
[ __ ] I'm gonna go [ __ ] I went down
there and for you and the Philly chicken
blood yeah it would pieces that but
anyway where's out there you know it's
feeding the homeless people and just you
know I mean it felt so [ __ ] good
doing that
what did you get out of it I just just
just thought I've got questions I fell
about my right I thought how [ __ ]
blessed I was I [ __ ] drag that I went
home and I [ __ ] thanked God for all my
[ __ ] adage I got on stage I told some
jokes we filled their bellies and then
we filled their souls with entertainment
and I got a date Jim aside of that guy
he doesn't want Thanksgiving he doesn't
Christmas it's tremendous tremendous
[ __ ] act kindness it was a I felt
[ __ ] great dish to be a part of it
just to get out of the house [ __ ] if
Ania - was there a feeling feeding
people and you know these people don't
have to do it this [ __ ] Tom dreesen
everybody's down there feeding people
making sure they had enough to eat and
then they went up on stage and gave them
a show and it's the way that when they
treat these people like [ __ ] human
beings I know this is [ __ ] vent that I
mean if Christmas ain't in your heart
ain't gonna find that underneath the
[ __ ] Christmas tree so it was a really
really cool thing to do I'll do whatever
year now and Thanksgiving Christmas I
thought was tremendous and so but yeah
but you can outside your own [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know and that's social media derives
everybody they all think they're all
caught up in their own [ __ ] I mean
go [ __ ] go down in the hospital and
[ __ ] read the [ __ ] sick kids Wayne
TEVAR getting the [ __ ] out of the
hospital or go feed some [ __ ] homeless
people go go to your I mean go through
some real [ __ ] I always say that can
outside of your [ __ ] itself if you
depress you get outside yourself you see
how [ __ ] lucky you got it you know you
know it's just I mean well I'll be doing
that again - on Thanksgiving what
happened dude he ran over a thousand
people through there thousand people
looking to us to hungry people just
[ __ ] having that a good mean not good
meal but just talking them you know we
treat them like human beings in the air
they were hey Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas given a plate of food here
watch his show was just phenomenal and
the kids coming in with toys they had
toys they could unwrap it was [ __ ]
amazing and
doesn't have to do that he'd been doing
it for 39 years I thought I was I
thought it was just uh it just I just
gotta [ __ ] move me man you know I
just thought it was something special I
was praising it a couple of bums
what's that couple 20s on Christmas Day
was funny cuz we in our Eric Rocha went
up to Oxnard last weekend oh yeah we
would always have to stop at the 101 by
Tonga and Magnolia Riverside this
there's homeless people living under
there and me and I would beat the horn
and there was no there weren't in there
they just weren't in there no there was
that [ __ ] was there but they weren't
damn like we open the window I would
open Lee's window and go hey I'm leaving
the life right now we're gonna get
killed here whatever you make the
right-hand turn and hit the 101 right
Christmas day I got up another student
then I'm like huh what the [ __ ] is gonna
allow my life I got I got to take a ride
anyway and I got in the car at that
light I finally saw the three homeless
dudes it's it's a black chick was
backpack and two white dudes and they
were dressing up like teddy bears they
were trying to hustle teddy bears so I
just beep the horn and gave me two
[ __ ] 20 Christmas Day and everything
the black chick looked at me like take
your dick out yeah like I've sucked up
420 I mean I've been hustling for
quarters and you just can't they have a
Starbucks they were happy that's it yeah
I mean that's the best I can [ __ ] do
on Christmas you know I know I'm
probably God do something you got dude
you gotta help somebody on Christmas I
think so it's that time of year you know
I think you know and you just sometimes
people like gift if you reflect on your
life and you look back you go god I'm
incredibly [ __ ] blessed you know am I
where I want to be no I'm gonna keep
working the world what's the [ __ ] be
somewhere else but you know sometime be
thankful for where you are you're still
alive like my man's like ma man says you
get up every morning is I'm my [ __ ]
Apple just be awake gonna [ __ ] right
side of the grass you know my old man is
85 you know I'm lucky enough to still
have them so I don't take any of that
for granted either I mean you know you
get to do something you love to do you
still got a great family I mean you know
[ __ ] knock what man God but you know
what is a special come on sugar the
special is gonna be dropping on January
15th people go to Jimmy Schubert calm
and it's Shu btrt like the theater
Jimmy Schubert calm it's gonna be
Vimy on demand but you could just go to
my website I'll take you on the Vimeo on
demand and plus it'll be on Vimeo but
I'll be tweeting about if people want to
check out my social media everything is
that Jimmy Schubert at Twitter and
Instagram and everything else there'll
be a big announcements coming so if they
found me on social media or they want to
check back January 15th which is a
Tuesday I'll be dropping my brand-new
hour special on Vimeo on demand so they
can rent it they can buy it they can do
whatever they want with it but uh I'm
really excited about this hour I worked
my ass off on it and so it's finally
coming out and I'm just going just going
right to the people then I tell people
all the time you Tom Rhodes all you guys
you guys are the backbones of comedy I
watch you guys and I always learned
something like and one the flip side of
the coin but the coin flips at any time
yeah and so I wish you all the luck in
the world I thank you very much for
helping yeah when I got here did - I'd
like the world to me and I can do the
same for lis and other guys I mean I
didn't understand that you have to pass
a long part of this is not about talent
yeah it's about passing out love to
somebody you're gonna help yeah [ __ ] the
Bobby Lee tells the stories or the back
back edges at the comic store he said he
hadn't eaten in three [ __ ] days ago
what the [ __ ] you waiting for come on if
[ __ ] took him down at Carney's a
[ __ ] chef that hot dog down his
throat
I said get something to [ __ ] go do
you [ __ ] I've been that guy had to sleep
on the [ __ ] roof of the Comedy Store
the [ __ ] sleeping my car had to crash
a crest til I wasn't allowed up there he
was trying to [ __ ] hustle make a
living hand till things got better I
totally get it man it was my pleasure
and that's my [ __ ] pleasure to see
you have this [ __ ] huge success that
you're having now I [ __ ] love you
Joey Diaz thank you thank you good luck
to you too don't forget
January 12th I'm at the [ __ ] ice
house just working out all the notes
have been doing the last two weeks all
coming out on the 12th come on by and
say hello then at the end of the month
the 20-something I don't know what
[ __ ] David is the 24th I'm in brain
probably the whole weekends it's the
last week of a January come on out and
say hello I want to thank Jimmy Schubert
for [ __ ] rocking it and if Netflix
ever does the five good guys at comedy I
hope you're on it cuz you're a really
[ __ ] good guy well thank you brother
I want to thank number one on it listen
it's January [ __ ]
you wanted to change your life it all
starts from within right and gold's
walking whatever little things you want
to do but at the same time you could
[ __ ] him go over to honor dr. Heim and
get the party started with you some
alpha brain or some shroom tech they're
[ __ ] goldenseal is the Alpha brain you
want to focus a little bit more [ __ ]
energy alpha brain is the way to go
listen it's their [ __ ] bread and
butter if you don't like it they'll give
you a refund and your money back without
the [ __ ] product only on it stands
behind their [ __ ] flagship product
like that so do me a favor if they have
that much belief how much believe she do
you have go to Hana calm right now and
press in search and get ten percent off
your order I could only help you with
supplements I cannot help you with
kettlebells or [ __ ] match anything
like that but you know what get them to
gives a [ __ ]
number two you want to start the year
off healthy you want to start the year
off smelling clean and nothing says I
love you like a clean [ __ ] [ __ ]
you understand me I bend you over I open
up those cheeks
I smell fumes of debt what do you expect
nobody cares ho everybody wants to look
[ __ ] but nobody wants to wash it
that's why you gotta go - hello - she
calm because they got portable days that
you would stall in seven minutes
and now from the end the [ __ ] time we
taste them when you die the car is gonna
look again going to taste them this
guy's answer I was in good shape why
because you got hello - [ __ ] calm go
down low - she calm right now and press
in muffler muffler and keep your muffler
clean they got a 60-day money-back
guarantee B and I'm gonna need it
because if it's held my fat stinky ass
for three years think what it could do
for your [ __ ] regular [ __ ] ass Lee
have you broken your hello fishy and no
it's still there and if they could pump
that humus fly-swatting off his neck ass
they'll take anything you understand me
well okay I can't even imagine what a
[ __ ] the [ __ ] hose tap sighs [ __ ]
now everything is intact go - hello -
she calm and press in my flirt and get a
portable bidet installed in your [ __ ]
house buy you seven minutes because
remember
help starts in you [ __ ] alright and
then you slip back a little bit you
watch the back side of your nutsack so
you don't develop any out guy or or
barnacles and I found the barnacle of my
nutsack about four years ago ever since
I've been with hell - she monocles I had
to go to a [ __ ] ship well the CEO at
the well the bar to come off my nut sack
go - hello - she's not comment present
muffler BAM and get that [ __ ] fresh
by Valentine's Day you understand me I
want to thank Jimmy two-shoes Schubert
go to Jimmy Schubert calm for a special
I want to thank the Christ's killing I
want to thank you guys for being loyal
soldiers are always loving me as much as
I love you take this [ __ ] to muley see
you guys Monday morning ready Iraq the
7th of January when this [ __ ] really
gets cooking
do your thing Lee